and here at the aau nationals for
each one teach one the aau team and
chris paul
looking like a ball handling pull-up
drill there
basically on the run out they couldn't
hit him in time kill just alexander to
the bucket and gets it you see why it's
been a struggle for him
he's now eight of 29 in the series from
three
two of eleven in game two gilges
alexander off class
chris paul nice in and out dribble pull
up and won
that's who they would like to target
frustration by pj tucker all right i'm
gonna dance you back a little bit
i'm gonna get to that best aspect of my
game
he slipped the screen got inside on
tucker that's a favorable matchup and
they convert
er gordon just missing the layup thunder
can get it down to two
chris paul steaming downhill gets the
layup james is using that arm to hook
but he's just going to dance off
galinari get himself into three-point
territory
the two years he spent chris paul
against
mclemore
boy chris paul was that a drill
[Music]
i mean he just lulled his defender
mclemore to sleep
gordon trying to guard the much bigger
and stronger adams
why doesn't he try to punish him on the
box didn't even look at the basket they
get one out of
gilgis alexander you're right doris
that was his first three on four
attempts chris paul to the basket
that's too easy if you're houston that's
you can see how frustrated mike d'antoni
is like you've got to play better
defense than that the screen on jeff
green for paul
hardin switches on to him paul gets to
the bucket
for the lead gilges alexander got it
the thunder lead by one he's going to
beat off the dribble
pitch it to the far corner and shay calm
he is doubtful to return for the last
two minutes and 15 seconds of this game
wow chris paul butter
chris paul did he just blow a kiss at
the camp shay alexander
for the three-point critical shot under
the rest of this shot clock come on come
on
come on and it's especially sweet
against a former teammate in austin
rivers